Quatrièmement, nous créons des thérapies intelligentes s'adaptant dans le corps
pour aller bien au-delà des traitements actuels,
qui sont vraiment des outils émoussés.
Par exemple, pour cibler un petit sous-ensemble de cellules immunitaires
responsables d'une maladie auto-immune,
et pour le distinguer de la vaste majorité des cellules immunitaires saines.
Enfin, inspirés par de remarquables matériaux biologiques
comme la soie, la coquille d'ormeau, la dent et bien d'autres,
nous concevons de nouveaux matériaux à base de protéines
afin de relever les défis énergétiques et écologiques.
Pour accomplir tout cela, nous développons notre institut.
Nous souhaitons attirer des scientifiques dynamiques, talentueux et variés
du monde entier, à toutes les étapes de leur carrière,
pour qu'ils nous rejoignent.
Vous pouvez aussi participer à la révolution de la conception des protéines
grâce à Foldit, notre jeu de pliage et de conception en ligne.
Ainsi qu'à travers Rosetta@home, notre projet informatique distribué,
que vous pouvez rejoindre depuis un ordinateur ou un smartphone Android.
Améliorer le monde grâce à la conception de protéines est l’œuvre de ma vie.
Je suis si impatient de ce que nous pouvons faire ensemble.
J'espère que vous vous joindrez à nous
et je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)